it took me a long time to come to terms
with casper i probably would hear can i
keep you for the rest of my life and
it's part of me and part of my past
and i'm grateful you may remember devon
sawa from
fan favorite films from the 90s like yes
casper can i keep you and now and then
can i kiss you fast forward to 2020
and the 42 year old actor is still
thriving earning praise for his work in
gritty dramas and edgy horror films
like his latest hunter hunter we don't
run from our troubles
now sawwa is opening up to e.t revealing
the journey hasn't always been easy
you know i was i was heartbroken and i
really thought about giving it up it was
more important what clubs i was going to
at night and
not necessarily the material but he says
it was all worth it to get where he is
today
i work with good people and good stuff
it makes me smile that's it what do you
do if you see something
don't run this isn't a normal wolf
it's just a hungry wolf looking for an
easy male i will catch it
when you snag a wolf you get out wolf
them
hunter hunter this movie it's chilling
it's twisted
and holy plot twist is it hard for you
to shake a character like this at the
end of the day
the script came to me about a week
before we started shooting
and um i knew this guy was very
different than i was
um i i mean i've been living in los
angeles for 20 years
you know i feel like i'm a little bit
pampered and spoiled
not a wilderness guy no i'm not a
wilderness guy i come from canada but
even
where i was from it wasn't you know was
it was you know little hockey town it
wasn't very wildernessy
um but i had to i had to put all my
trust in the director right away and
figure out how to be
as authentic as possible with this guy
um
learn how to skin animals properly
um you know not real animals but we had
we faked it very well everything from
from sharpening knives to
to the cigarette process was a little
bit challenging
and the conditions that we were under in
in winnipeg they were dealing with a
record snowstorm at the time
first you lose your feet you know they
start they start going numb and then you
get the red frost bites up and down your
legs and
the backpack starts getting heavy and
you want to put the gun down and uh all
that
uh feeling uncomfortable really just
kind of played into the
into the script wow losing sensation in
your feet
smoking real cigarettes you are a true
method actor
um but like at the end i sound like such
a spoiled actor
like that's all i had to do was like
stand in the cold and smoke a couple of
cigarettes no no no anybody
i'd be wise to sit here with you and not
do a little fun
career retrospective yeah i told you i
was a good dancer
casper
[Music]
that was great it's okay it's like i
have no control over my hands
for showing the range of work that
you've done you know comedy and the
feel-good movies and now you're doing
more like
niche indie gritty types of dramas and
horror films
do you feel like you get the recognition
respect and opportunities that you
deserve as an artist
good question um i think that the my
team beat
uh past uh
affects certain things you know that
that that comes up i've been in the cat
you know casting sessions where where
that that has all come up at the 90s
team
you know it's been it's been i don't
know if an issue but it put a topic
i think that that kind of weighs me down
sometimes going forward
but i wouldn't be here where i am today
without that stuff
it took me a long time to come to terms
with casper believe it or not as weird
as that sounds
but i did finally come to terms that i
probably would hear can i keep you for
the rest of my life and it's part of me
and part of my past and
uh i'm grateful um i
i'm just so darn fortunate that i'm
still going at this thing and that
i get the opportunities that i get i
work with travolta and stallone and guy
pierce just in the last couple of years
sharon stone i didn't see him with
sharon stone that was
i couldn't believe i was there that she
was playing my cracked out mother and
i'm
forever grateful that i'm here where i
am
well it got me here i have to tell you i
think you're in your prime and the work
that i see you do
especially in the last couple of years
it's really you at your best and
i know only the best is yet to come what
is on the bucket list
you know i went away for a few years uh
for five or six years and i came back
and i i swore that i would only do stuff
that makes that makes me happy when i
was doing those team magazines casper
and while married all that stuff i was
going that way
and then i decided i was going to rebel
as a young 19 year old
you know stick it to the to the business
and do
i started doing things like slc punk and
idle hands and stand video and that was
my
that was my rebelling and i'm back to
that again but back to the just doing
what makes me
what what makes what i want to do like
like doing a movie with the
the escape plan sequel was stallone
wasn't necessarily
i knew from the beginning it wasn't
necessarily going to catapult me into
anything but it was stallone and
i loved that guy and i wanted to work
with him and and and
that's kind of where i'm at right now i
work with good people and good stuff
that makes me smile that's it
i love it you reference you took a
little break from hollywood i'm curious
why was that break
necessary and do you think you'd be in
the position you are today
if you hadn't put a pause back then
it was it wasn't really it was a break
that
wasn't a lot of my choice really and it
was my
it was my agents and managers and myself
sitting down and saying hey
i think it's time we we step away for a
minute
and uh and i really thought about giving
it up and completely i
i was i've been working since the age of
eight or nine i was burnt out and i was
doing things that i didn't want to do
and it was more important what clubs i
was going to at night and
not necessarily the material and uh i
stepped away
and uh and things just changed and
uh and then i came back to the industry
with with with a whole new
outlook and ready to do it differently
is there a hollywood heartbreak moment
was there a role that you ever went out
for
that you really wanted and you got close
but not yeah
the anakin skywalker role in in the uh
in the star star was there was funny
because there was five of us
going up for that and then they ended up
going with hayden christensen
um from vancouver i mean he did a great
job so but
you know i was i was heartbroken yeah
was that project like particularly
meaningful to you huge star wars right
gigantic star wars guy especially as a i
was gigantic to think to play a young
darth vader in what was
going to be the biggest thing ever no
one knew what those films were going to
be
um but it was it was like everybody
wanted those parts and
i came i want to say i came close
you did you said top five that's
definitely close and they keep talking
about all these spin-offs you got
mandalorian now i'd say we throw your
name in the hat for all of those
i'm i'm i'm down i'm down i'm down to
partner up with gina carano and go uh
go kick some blood on there of course
this wouldn't be a devin sawa interview
if i didn't go down into the et vault
and dig up some
amazing vintage footage so this
is you on this set of wild america
yeah and you're being asked about what
you and jonathan taylor thomas
do in your spare time oh no yeah we talk
about girls yeah we talk about girls you
know
yeah we we talk a lot about stuff like
that girls you know
movies cds we really we never talk about
the business range
and that's that's really cool so so you
guys are going to kind of like
get to worry about this whole heartthrob
thing you worried about that
it's challenging i understand it gets a
little annoying it gets a little uh a
little rough at times but you know
it's very flattering what's going
through your mind
[Music]
such a baby baby back then i think about
that kid a lot i was 18 and um
the amount of things that we had to deal
with
that age like what
this just the whole stardom thing the
whole being the center of attention
um it was it was
challenging at times it was it was
definitely challenging i i get
kind of sad a little bit because i know
where i was going right after that you
know what i mean i know
i know i know in hollywood where i'm
about to go
at that point i think wild america and
idle hands were both the last before
things started to get a little bit
rougher in hollywood from there
um so yeah it's a little
it's a little weird to watch that
knowing what's gonna happen knowing the
outcome of what's gonna happen
it's an interesting video i'd do
anything just to go along for the ride
what was the last time you and jonathan
taylor thomas had a moment to chat or
catch up
we spoke on the phone a couple of years
ago it was the time where i was having
the fake fight with uh
macaulay culkin oh and macaulay culkin
and him were about to do something and
they were going to see if
uh if i would be involved in it it was
going to be like a kind of a
mockumentary
tv show where where we are now but just
like
not really us you know what i mean like
almost like a curb your enthusiasm
of conversion heightened versions of
where we are today
um never ended up going anywhere but it
was good to speak to him i always had a
feeling that um
from doing school with him that he was
gonna go off and do things other than
acting
because he was just so smart and um
so to find out he went off to harvard
and uh
took a different road was not surprising
but i'm
you know he's i miss him he's a good guy
this weekend amazing timing
on snl doing a whole m m stand
parody don't forget bring my gift truly
yours i believe in you
this is stew
i don't think i've smiled so much in a
long time uh i think uh
i think he nailed people don't see some
of the things that i saw
uh he did everything from the pencil
blow to the
certain eye rolls to different uh like
he was
he really kind of copied me perfectly
but also
you know did his own thing and spun it
his own way and
and uh i'm very flattered that i was in
a music video that's lasted
so long did you have any idea that this
was happening no
somebody else tweeted that like they're
doing a stan parody and i my first
reaction was like oh you know they
are they gonna they're gonna give it a
party but he he is
there's nothing it's just funny it's
just they took the song twisted it
and he uh he's a talented dude that guy
[Music]
are you coming back to la for the
holidays i am
okay i'm coming back for uh
for christmas and uh we're going to
spoil the kids because they've had a
rough year
um you know with with the quarantining
so i'm going to put my i'm going to put
grinch aside and try to
and try to have the best christmas ever
just the four of us and
the dogs and we're going to put up a
christmas tree and have lots of good
food and open presents and
and watch you know die hard or something
i don't know
you